[Música]
en las noticias económicas de hoy vamos
a darle una mirada a lo que ha ocurrido
en la guerra en Ucrania y Es que desde
que comenzó este conflicto en Rusia
muchas marcas muchas industrias
occidentales se fueron del país pero sus
productos no Daniela Blandón bienvenida
y cuéntenos un poco al respecto Muchas
gracias María Clara Buenos días Pues
dicen que a menudo se ven camiones con
coca-cola cruzando las fronteras para
entrar en Rusia o los turistas ingresan
desde el extranjero cargados con los
últimos diseños de Sara y los mercados
locales pueden conseguirse muebles de
Ikea con un rublo que sigue fuerte y que
está favoreciendo estas compras por qué
sucede esto Pues a pesar de que las
empresas europeas norteamericanas y
también japonesas abandonaron Rusia por
su invasión de Ucrania el impacto de los
consumidores es mínimo según una
investigación de la agencia reuters Como
coca-cola por ejemplo que dejó de
producir y vender bebidas en este país
pero otros la han estado
desde Europa desde kazajstán o desde
Uzbekistán inclusive desde china pero
más allá de estas importaciones Daniela
Cómo estos productos típicamente
occidentales logran entrar a Rusia pues
mire la gran mayoría de estos bienes no
están sujetos a sanciones y Estos flujos
transfronterizos son legales porque
cuando las cadenas de suministro
colapsaron Rusia legalizó las llamadas
importaciones paralelas algunos llegaron
a decir incluso que esto era contrabando
esto permite a los minoristas traer
productos del extranjero sin el permiso
del propietario de la marca y a Moscú
por supuesto le conviene dejarlos entrar
sea cual sea la ruta que tomen la
diferencia con lo que ya estaban
acostumbrados los rusos es que por
supuesto los plazos de entrega pueden
ser más largos y algunos productos más
caros bueno Daniela mientras en Rusia
las personas padecen los efectos de
estas sanciones y estas retiradas que
como vemos son parciales porque los
productos continúan en Hong Kong la
pandemia del Coby 19 es la que está
generando efectos Y hoy por hoy el
gobierno le va a dar dinero a los
ciudadanos para hacerle frente a la
crisis pues mire este territorio
semiautónomo se ha propuesto recuperar
su economía sea como sea como de lugar a
comienzos de este mes el presidente
ejecutivo del centro financiero global
John Lee anunció una campaña para
regalar 500.000 tiquetes de avión a
partir de marzo para Los visitantes
extranjeros y les quitó toda restricción
de cuarentenas ahora el beneficio está
dirigido a sus propios ciudadanos en el
proyecto de presupuesto 2023 y 2024 fue
incluido un Bono de 5000 dólares
hongeses Estos son más o menos 640
dólares para cada adulto la mitad de un
Bono que ya habían entregado en 2022 Ya
esta ciudad ha gastado más de 76 mil
millones de dólares en programas de
alivio por la pandemia y esto la ha
llevado a incurrir en déficit
presupuestarios que son muy inusuales en
esta zona lista entonces para irse a
Hong Kong Sí claro con esos tiquetes
rega bueno y nos vamos a India porque
allí se reúnen los ministros de finanzas
del g20 bueno la reunión se va a
extender hasta el sábado en el centro
tecnológico de bangalore que tiene dos
temas principales la inflación
obstinadamente alta y también el aumento
de la deuda sobre todo en países pobres
una de las visitas más esperadas es la
de la secretaria del tesoro de Estados
Unidos Janette no solamente por el hecho
de que representa a la economía más
grande del mundo sino porque justo hoy
miércoles el mercado está esperando las
minutas de la más reciente reunión de la
reserva federal y eso les va a dar luces
a los principales líderes financieros de
este bloque sobre si la inflación ya
está en un nivel suficientemente cómodo
que permita desacelerar ese aumento de
tasas de interés Aunque la guerra en
Ucrania también y sus consecuencias van
a dominar la agenda pero India que
ostenta la presidencia de este grupo de
principales economías también debe
caminar con mucho cuidado ya que es uno
de los grandes beneficiados de la compra
de petróleo Ruso y con descuento además
y hable de ganancias y pérdidas de las
empresas Cómo se están moviendo bueno
Seguimos entonces en el mes de
presentación de resultados el turno es
para la cadena mundial de pizzas
Domino's cuya franquicia en Australia
reportó una caída cercana al 30% en sus
ganancias del primer semestre fiscal
terminado en diciembre Ese es el peor
desempeño desde 2011 e hizo que sus
acciones cayeran 24% antes de la
apertura del mercado en su mayor
desplome de la historia Cuál es la razón
desde luego una caída en los pedidos a
medida que los precios suben por la
inflación también reveló resultados el
grupo francés el mayor productor de
yogur del mundo sus ventas en el cuarto
trimestre del año pasado crecieron 7%
pero redujo sus márgenes de utilidad a
pesar de que aumentó sus precios como
también lo hicieron sus rivales Nestlé y
Unilever y finalizamos con una noticia
de Starbucks qué tanto le gusta el café
María Clara bastante pero le voy a decir
yo prefiero Juan Valdez el colombiano Ah
bueno Me parece muy bien Pues resulta
que Juan Valdez no va a cometer este
error que creo que va a cometer
Starbucks Y es que lanzó en Italia su
nuevo producto y es un café con infusión
de aceite de oliva un experimento que
llevará a otros países ojalá que no a
Colombia porque yo no quiero ver esa
señora y qué cifra nos tiene para este
miércoles 5,4 millones de turistas María
Clara esto es una buena noticia para
nuestro país porque esto es lo que
espera el gobierno colombiano para este
año una cifra que El Ejecutivo proyecta
llevar a siete coma cinco millones en
2026 como parte de un plan para el
sector que prevé pues para ese momento
ingresos que alcancen los 10.000
millones de dólares le tengo un dato de
cierre Y es que este país sudamericano
es el quinto más atractivo del mundo por
sus recursos naturales de acuerdo con el
foro económico mundial todo el resto
también está en en este continente
la puede viajar a Colombia en vez de ir
a Hong Kong Sí señora y me sale mucho
más barato y le sale más barato Daniela
Gracias por las noticias económicas nos
vemos en una hora